thank you too hello everyone this is
actually my first time at geo scholar
from really excited to be here and I'm
really excited to talk to you about
server less apps powered by web
components so before we dive in I just
want to give a bit of context so I work
for the Guardian as a senior engineer
and I work permanently on editorial
tools which is the domain to being the
new Guardian CMS called composer and a
new media service for managing images
now all these tools are built as web
apps and they follow the same sort of
three tier architecture which is this
one so that means that you've got the
front end at the front which is the
browser and your code running in a
browser so typically we use angularjs
for that then the back end which is our
cert the code running on your servers
for that we usually use scholar and
things like place killara and then
finally this the data is stored in the
database we use elasticsearch mangu and
other things and these are typically
referred to as sort of presentation and
turn that off because it's going to
annoy me keep treating me presentation
middle tier and data storage tiers so
this is what we going to refer to in the
rest of this presentation just keep that
in mind let's move on so the idea for
this thought came about a few months
back when I started getting increasingly
jealous of this information radiator
that one of my colleague built and it's
the for the responsive front-end sites
it shows them a lot of information about
the health of the server key system
metrics KPIs the deployment status
health service and so on so that's
that's a really useful thing to have at
the end of your desk and compare that to
what we had in my team yet it was a bit
meh so why is it may it's not just
because it looks a bit [ __ ] it's also
because it's quite complex it's complex
as a user because I actually had to be
on the VPN to access it so something
was wrongly on the know in a restaurant
you can't login on the VPN with your
phone is really tedious and also it was
complex as a developer because sometimes
you want to change these dashboards if
something goes bad like that in the last
week we had some problems and we needed
to start monitoring a new queue then
it's really hard it was quite tedious to
add new things to this dashboard because
he was deployed somewhere and also he
was written in this horrible PHP code so
that's one aspect the other side of that
is that it's also very rigid because the
only pull data from one source graphite
which is our internal monitoring servers
and also the configuration was very much
mixed in with this horrible PHP code a
dimension which made it really hard to
edit and manipulate graphs the way I
said I would like to be able to do so
when something is not good what you do
you put in the bin and then you say well
let's build a better one so let's try
and build a better one so going back to
this architecture I presented earlier so
we know that we've got the data storage
this is where data is so it can be
possibly in graphite which is the
current so what we have for more legacy
systems and more and more we're moving
towards AWS so the Amazon Web Services
which has its own monitoring service
called cloud watch that's what we're
going to focus on for the rest of this
presentation because that's where
services are moving so that's where the
data is and we know that we want to have
the presentation layer display the graph
in your browser so that's that's what
we've got now what about this middle
tier thing what happens with it do we
need it well so i really love scholar
but one thing i love even more than
Scala is not having to write any code or
maintain any servers that might go down
and so on you have to monitor the
monitors it's really boring so what can
we just get rid of it let's see what we
actually need it for in the first place
well traditionally I think I've
identified three things that you would
tend to do on this middle tier the first
one is both survivor I mean both
authentication which is knowing who the
person is and then authorization which
is determining what the missions they
have in the system once you know that
they can come in you can okay great I
can query the database on their behalf
and retrieve some data and once I've got
the day
can just render it that's the simplest
thing that the middle tier does and
that's usually what he would do if you
implemented it in any language there's a
few other things obviously that service
do like serving the actual files may be
cashing serving data but let's let's
leave that on the side for now so let's
see can we can we do all of that on the
client instead list let's say we've got
a static HTML page and we're going to
write all of this in JavaScript so how
do we start we start with the oath
aspects now actually AWS gives us nice
primitives for that because they support
this idea of credentials that you can
create and then once you've got these
credentials which is a key and a secret
don't try and copy those they're not
real and the region and once you've got
that you can define the permissions that
they have so I'm going to define
actually these credentials all they can
do is query cloud watch they can't spin
up new servers and so on all you can do
is just read the metrics data so now i
can define them and put them in the page
like this and I've got my oath sorted
right so that's in JavaScript so now
I've got my oath I can pass it into I'm
going to do a query with it so to do
that I'm going to use the AWS jss DK
it's an open source sdk you can go and
download it it's the same as UK as in
other languages and it lets you query
the able to be a services so you just
create a new instance of the cloud watch
service with the credentials we've
passed in earlier and then you can call
the method to get metric statistics and
you pass into power meters that are
going to define what you querying so
here we're going to actually look at the
request count so the number the request
rates in a certain a given load balancer
for given time and summit and when we
when we do this asynchronously we get
the required response back that's what
we see at the bottom here and I'm in
that squat that's quite a dub your
specific so we might actually transform
that don't look at this code but
basically you transform it into a time
series which is a simple array of pairs
and in the pair you got the first item
is the time the event happened at and
then the second item is the value very
simple data structure so we've got our
data now we've got our metrics data so
we need to do is to render it so I'm
lazy so I'm not
do that myself I'm going to just load in
Google chart and write this it's
actually quite it's quite a lot of
boilerplate here it's quite ugly but
yeah that's why you had to do this from
the example on their dot in their dogs
and in the middle hair we actually see
that we add the rows in the middle of
this big blob of JavaScript and at the
end we also say okay select this element
and then inject the graph at that place
in the page and then we get a graph
that's great okay job done let's go all
go to the pub well not quite because so
we've fixed the first aspect it's no
longer complex because it's just the
static HTML page in my browser it's
really easy to edit there's no VPN crap
anymore there's no horrible PHP anymore
so that's sorted but in terms of
rigidity we're still pulling from only
one data source we now you reading from
AWS but that's still just only one and
the configuration was mixed into all
this spaghetti code I showed you earlier
so that's not very nice which means that
it's not very easy to add and change
graphs quite rapidly so I'd say it's not
better enough so what can we do what do
we actually want ideally what we want is
not to have any of this boilerplate we
just want to say i want this graph of
requests and well that sounds very much
like just an element right can we do
that with an element so i'm sure
hopefully you know where I'm going with
this so web components who in the room
knows what have hazard of web components
cool who has tried web components quite
a lot great so a quick primer so a web
component is dissing Society of a custom
element so you could say okay this this
google map element that will show a map
of this geo position okay if you put
this in your browser it's not going to
work magically right it's just going to
do nothing so how does that work well
the thing is you the idea of web
components is that you can teach the
browser how to do what to do with this
when it sees it this in the page so you
can define the behavior when it sees a
custom element and make it do anything
you want all of this you program in java
script so once you've defined once
you've written the code for this you
need to import it into your page so that
it's in scope this is very much like you
they border style sheets to sort of
change the presentation of your page
this is simply using the HTML imports
and once you've got an HTML import well
actually all of this is in fact it
doesn't really it's kind of using
futuristic AP is so you need to use
polyfills and for this I we use platform
Jas which is a library Google right to
polyfill all the web components ap is so
that a work in all recent browsers so
you can really think of web components
as if HTM elements are sort of your
classic Lego blocks web components are
like the lego mindstorm you can do
anything so we're going to use web
components we're actually going to use a
layer on top of that we're going to use
polymer which is this library google
wrote as well on top of platform jas you
don't have to use it to use web
components in fact you can use other
ones like x tags from mozilla if you
prefer but let's use the polymer because
it has a few niceties such as this
filament scaffolding declarative syntax
so we see in this example that we just
import polymer so that we can use the
polymer element element to define new
element called margarita and then it
takes only one attribute called name we
see at the bottom we use it we just have
a tag margarita and we pass in my name
Seb as an attribute now back to the
declaration we see that the template is
actually this is what the we're going to
put in the shadow Dom I'm not gonna
explain with the shadow DOM is but
basically this is going to what is going
to appear in your page instead of the
migrator element then it's going to say
hello and then my name because this is
the data binding syntax so polymer
suppose bi-directional data binding
which means that it's going to replace
the name sort of curly thing I you with
it with the value of the attribute here
Seb and actually because it start by
directional you can also bind it to this
input text where it's going to give the
initial value to the input text tab but
then if you change it is going to change
the value everywhere for that variable
so this is actually really powerful and
we're going to use that throughout the
rest of this presentation okay so let's
dive in
or not a pegar so we've got this AWS
config element we've created a new
element called AWS config i'm going to
show the implementation in a second and
it basically takes three attributes
region key and secret and we just pass
in string values that are to the to the
attributes what does this element do
well nothing so that's not very useful
it just takes in some data and there's
nothing there's nothing to display its
just a configuration thing so what do we
do with it well what we can do is add a
new attribute let's call it sink for
convention and to say that sink is
actually an attribute where we're going
to write out what the sort of the output
of this element is as data and here
we're going to output it to a variable
will AWS config and the variable is
going to contain something like this
which is exactly what we had earlier as
you saw a JavaScript so actually if we
go to the implementation it looks very
similar to what we did earlier so we
load in polymer then we see I've got a
new element called alias config with
four attributes and then I declare how
this element works so I'm going to say
I'm observing the first three attributes
the three inputs and whenever any of the
changes I'm going to update I'm also
going to update when the element is
ready which means it's been put in the
page so what does update do well it just
checks that three inputs are there and
if they are we just create a new object
and write it add assign it to the sink
property which will basically set it to
this variable that we databound great
okay so I've got this this element by
the way all of this is open source so
there's github URL so you can all go and
play with this you can just make your
own so we've got our credentials now as
a variable so we can pass it into this
cloud watch element which is going to
abstract the same JavaScript code we had
earlier which does the querying using
the SDK so i'm not going to show the
code for that but basically we have this
element that takes the config as input
and then the parameters as attributes as
well and then it's going to have its own
sink attribute that's going to write
asynchronously when the data comes back
it's going to write the value into this
variable AWS metrics requests that's
going to contain time series
we also see that you can pass in an AWS
dimension sort of serb element just the
same way you do like an option inside a
select for instance okay so we've got
our data and it looks very much like
what we had before just thing working it
looks very much like what we had before
which is this time series data so we can
pass it into the render element now
actually because I'm super lazy i'm
actually not even going to write it i'm
just going to steal it from Google
because Google wrote their own custom
element I don't know if added did but
their own google chart element that
wraps their Google chant library and you
can see there's actually a lot less of
this horrible boilerplate than before so
that's already a nice a nice win so I'm
just passing in my data as grows and
then I define how it's going to look and
there we go we've got our chat so that's
cool and we've got all of this through
web components so what does it look like
n to n so n to n we have with three
we've got our three string attributes
that we pass into the a tablet config
element that's going to write it using
the sink to a new variable AWS config we
pass that to cloud Watch alongside other
parameters that's going to do the Ajax
request and when it comes back we can
write that into another variable and
pass that to google chat and boom our
tracks appears great what does that look
like in code well it's very similar in
fact so we load in platform jas at the
top which is the polyfills we import our
three elements and then we use them
within this sort of auto binding context
that gives us the data binding thing and
that's it this is the three elements so
that works for a single chart if we end
up having more charts more requests
charts you can already tell that it's
going to duplicate quite a lot of code
so we end up with something like this
where there's a lot of code duplication
and as you know don't repeat yourself
it's not very clean to copy paste code
you shouldn't be doing it if you're
doing it you're doing it wrong probably
so how do you how do you abstract this
when typical programming what you do is
you parameterize it as a function right
and then the bits that changed you make
them parameters of the function and
you've abstract it away so here we're
going to use it an element are you going
to use an element instead and we're
going to make the two inputs is going to
be the config and the load balance name
which are the only two things that
change in all of this code so we can
abstract this as a new aw this requests
element
and we just pass in the load balancer
name great and then right let me know if
you can use it and we've done what we
wanted we've got a new a dubious request
element and that displays a graph of the
request for this load balancer great and
actually we can do this so we've done it
for requests we can show latency you can
show like look at the numbers of two
counts in a custom metric you can do
anything you want and because we've
based this on small sort of atomic
modules you can actually replace some of
the like some of the pieces of the
puzzle so you can replay actually let's
fetch the data from another source let's
fetch the data from graphite instead of
AWS cloud watch croft is a completely
different server we access it over
breast and so on but because we output
this in the same data formats
interesting that's our impressive web
components are so so big because we use
the same data format we can pass it into
the google chart and it works just the
same so a bit confession a small
confession we've actually cheated all
along so sorry about that I don't know
if you noticed but everywhere we passed
in the exact sort of string values for
the time well that's a bit stupid isn't
it like that means we're always watching
a given sort of time range time interval
for all our data that's not a very
useful graph so what can we do instead
so what we want what we want is probably
just to say okay I want to see the last
hour of data so how do we do that well
the last hour data means that the time
interval ends now so we're just going to
create a new variable that stores then
our time and where this now come from
where there's an element for that so we
just create a new time now element
that's going to export the time when
it's initialized and the time the now
variable will store a date time that is
passed into the cloud watch element
that's great except well it's just it
doesn't update where we can make it
update we can just pass in a refresh
attribute that says update every minute
and that means that actually the nice
thing here is that when now updates
after a minute now denard value changes
and because cloud watch is also
observing these inputs is going to
update
the is going to do another request to
fetch the updated data and because the
grub the charting element also watches
its inputs is going to update the graph
so we've got a complete it's like
function of reactive program or reactive
programming where you define the data
flow and then everything updates without
having to explicitly listen for special
events nobody knows about the other
things happening it's just data bound so
we're not quite done yet because the
start time is still hard coded so what
we said we wanted to have a span on a
time interval of one hour so let's do
that let's define a time range element
that says one hour and then we bind the
end now which means that the start is
going to be an output which will be
which you can attach to the cloud which
element so we've got now our time range
of one hour that's enforced and when now
changes start changes except we're still
not done because the number of hours is
fixed what do we want we probably want
to custom number of hours because what
if your service died a horrible death
like an hour and a half ago well that
you want to be able to change that time
range so if you say the user needs to do
it what we want a bit of a UI element so
again i'm lazy so i'm not going to write
my own i'm just going to steal this one
from google and that's what they're for
so we're just going to take the paper
element which is some custom element
they've written and that's going to
output export a simple integer value
that we're going to bind as ours and
when I change the value here as we can
see in the gift then that changes the
number of hours and just sent the same
way as when now changes that cascades
down changes the data and renders again
if you change the number of hours as a
user it just kids kids down and changes
the one you see in the graph
automatically so that's that's pretty
neat this is what the code looks like
we're not going to spend too long but
yeah you can review the slides later
another thing we did which we cheated a
bit upon is we've hardly a secret in the
page now if you are security expert or
even if you know if we should know that
this is not a good thing to do so you
don't wanna put secrets in the page
because if someone sees that page that
means they can access your you're the
inquiry perhaps no your servers are
that's not a super dangerous but it's
still not a very nice thing to do so you
probably don't want to do that but how
do you do it because you need to
authenticate with your servers well what
we can do is you can use this magical
thing cause the AWS web identity
federation and this is provided by AWS
and it lets you acquire talking with the
third party or always provider like
Google Facebook or Amazon and then you
trade that token for a temp temporary
set of AWS credentials that you can
define permissions for and this is what
I've done here we've written a new AWS
identity element that wraps the Google
sign-in element that Google actually
provided this is they had to write it
for me so that's nice and that exports
the same AWS config object as the
previous element did so you can just
substitute this sort of hard coded
config we had previously with this one
that does it in a safer way and without
revealing any secrets so that's nice so
let's do a live demo maybe okay alright
so let's reload this and see if it still
works okay so this is just a demo
radiator I've made so we see on the
right that is this tag API metrics so
that symmetrix actually they appear here
because the defect from graphite and the
way we restrict or graphite is simply
ip-based which I have to be on the VPN
for this and the other thing we see is
these weird rounded colored dots and
that these represent deploys to either
production or pre production
environments whether they've succeeded
or failed so this is you know this is
data that's live for from today from now
and so as I said we're going to use this
AWS identity element to do the oath so
this is the Google sign-in element this
is what it looks like this is the button
for it so I'm just going to click it and
see whether that works or not so I'm
just going to need to out with Google
and that trades a token that gets Google
token back trades it with Amazon and
gets temp set of temporary credentials
that I can use them to query cloud watch
every
databound and this is the data appears
here magically so we can see things like
this so you've got the latency requests
and all the bucket in and this is a
static page on this is just a Python
server that serves a static HTML file
there's no servers involved apart from
the a debris of services and that's all
using web components
another said because you can you can
change that you can simply change what
time window you're looking at in
automatically updates just through the
magic of data binding so that's also
really neat because you don't have to
write complex logic to update yet so
that's for the demo right obviously
that's going to walk now
so does that mean we can all like say
[ __ ] servers I'm just going to write my
JavaScript code from now on and you know
don't need to do anymore as servers I'm
just going to talk to the database until
at the end of times from now on well not
quite partly because well it's these web
well if you use the web components the
support is still fairly limited in that
it doesn't for all browsers especially
all browsers all the browsers and you
might want to support that the other
thing is as we saw we querying the
database directly from the browser that
doesn't really scale very well so for
things with low traffic like something
that developers are used or even
internal users use that's fine you can
use that but if you wouldn't put that on
the front of the guiding website don't
think Patrick would like that very much
so that would not very they would not
scale very well the other thing is we
want to have a system for authentication
especially if you're doing read right
but even reading sort of sensitive data
like this so for this you need to really
the only sort of component you can rely
on is the backend you can't rely on the
front end to do that because the front
end anyway they won't anyone can write
it so you need support from your
back-end services and you can do that
with IP restrictions so you can do that
with things like AWS policies but the
policies are quite coarse grained so you
couldn't say okay you can only update
this column in this database so there's
a bit of sort of limitations that make
it a bit harder to use for right
services but you know you can still do
it for things like this and quite a lot
of other cases in the future I think
there's more things we want to do with
this dashboard this is kind of just the
beginning so showing deploy lines on
graphs or showing KPI graphs like how
many images are added every day surfer
single javascript errors we use the
century service to capture them so it'd
be great to see when there's a spike
after deploy so you've probably broken
everything and see the server health and
yeah so a lot of more things you could
add to these servers carrying on the
same pattern so what have you learned so
far I think we've shown that it's
possible to remove this middle tier and
that makes it that makes the whole
system a lot simpler to maintain it to
edit it works in a variety of cases the
other thing you can we can we
is that you can use web components as
atomic programmable blocks like Lego
blocks and then you can combine them
using data binding or composition or
events and that lets you create a quite
a complex system out of very simple
blocks that you can then substitute and
so that's it that's it that's what I've
got and as I said all of this is open
source and you can check it out so i'll
recommend you go and play with it and
file like a bug report and everything
and play with it I home it's safe that's
all thank you very much